à la foire de paris la cuisine devient
bavarde pour les hommes et les femmes
qui font la cuisine où il via désormais
de quoi donner de la voix les appareils
électroménagers répondent donne des
conseils et obéissent reportage mary
pierce amitié avec aurélie legrand ou
vau-l'eau je voulais
essayer
d'élever fermer les volets elle
s'appelle d'homos l écoute et elle
répond descend le même lavage et l'oubli
à 250 ordres programmés
cet extraordinaire
et même par téléphone par et sinon on
peut programmer son travail est
excellent
acheter une clim comme ça si j'avais les
moyens oui messieurs
est dommage pour l'instant son prix qui
semblent y franc n'est accessible qu'aux
milliardaire l'ingénieur qui l'a conçue
a prévu des conseils de sécurité
la pluie n'était pas elle restera chaude
quelques instants pour être sûrs d'être
bien compris la machine il faut
impérativement créer une phrase sujet
verbe complément sujet de mots c'est le
verbe sévère d'action est le complément
c'est le nom de l'objet que vous voulez
actionné par exemple d'homos montrent le
four
l'accès à internet est prévu pour les
recettes de cuisine d'hognoul avantage
c'est que d'homos n'oublie rien sur le
feu je passe à l'étape suivante autre
nouveauté la hotte aspirante
télescopique elle se tourne vers les
mauvaises odeurs
mais attention fosse à ce raz-de-marée
high tech les cuisines rétro font de la
résistance
elles ont encore beaucoup de succès
les cuisine rustique représente encore
20% de parts de marché mais en les
achetant les français n'oublient pas
elle n'arrête pas le progrès